and so that's the funny thing going on
in the Republican party right now
is there's this game of
manufacturing the anti-establishment
Aura yep but the thing on the inside of
it is like about his establishment as it
gets and I think that there is there are
a couple candidates one in particular
Who are the
manifestation of that in the Republican
party right now
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the pleasure and honor of
sitting this morning with Vivek
ramaswamy did I pronounce your name
correctly Vivek you nailed it actually I
nailed it excellent I was hoping that I
would
um and I feel a bit of relief that
having done so so let me say uh I will
give you more of a chance to say who you
are and what we might want to talk about
but up front let's just say you correct
me if I'm wrong you're a Serial
entrepreneur you have background in
biotech and you are currently a
candidate for the Republican nomination
for the presidency
that's correct
and you're also an author I will say
you've written an excellent book uh on
how your perspective came to be anything
else my audience should know yeah I
wrote uh it says it was that woke ink
that you read or yes yeah good I've
written three books actually in the last
couple of years woke ink was the first
of the three and uh
I don't fashion myself as a author or
writer but I happen to be a guy who's
done some things that wrote some books
along the way but uh the books
definitely reflect my evolution of
thinking in the last few years and got
me to the doorstep of where I am as a
presidential candidate now
wonderful so let me give you a little
bit of perspective on on what I think
this conversation should entail
this I've done a lot of thinking about
American politics and the presidency in
particular
um I think Americans misunderstand their
own electoral process and it has created
a kind of uh reflex in them during
election season that I think is very
unproductive so what I see is that
Americans spend a lot of time asking
potential
uh presidential candidates to promise
them things about policy what will you
do when you're in office and I think
this is a mistake two different ways
one I think this is really an act of
desperation where people realize they
have very little control over the
process of governance and that the only
way that they could possibly exert any
force that would work in their direction
is to get people to tell them that they
will do things if they ascend to the
office and then hope that they will be
too embarrassed not to do it when they
get there and that's total failure I
also think it misunderstands what the
office of President really is right yeah
yeah it's not legislative so I'm not
going to do that I'm not going to ask
you about policy I must I just say one
quick thing on that please on the second
thing yeah um
which is that actually there's a funny
thing about most of my so-called
presidential platform
are actually not what my wishlist
legislative agenda would be for the very
reason you described it like every
presidential candidate every successful
president makes this mistake and you
know Trump was going to repeal and
replace Obamacare what came of that
nothing because you require this thing
called Congress
so most of what I'm focused on anyway is
what a president can do in running the
executive branch of the government so
anyway number two I'm in VM in agreement
with and I agree with you that most not
only people but most presidential
candidates misunderstand the process of
what it actually means to run for U.S
president yeah great so where I'm going
to focus uh and this is probably uh too
much inside baseball but back in 2020 I
started an initiative called the unity
2020 initiative and it was about trying
to
um draft candidates who would actually
serve Us in the office of the presidency
and we had three criteria that we wanted
people to have before they were worthy
of our consideration we wanted
courageous capable Patriots right
nothing ideological but my feeling is
look if you're courageous enough to
confront power if you're capable you
know how to do things uh and you're
patriotic you love this country then
what I really want to do is set you free
to do what you're good at to consult the
right people to figure out what the
right policy is and even if it's
something I didn't think to ask for if
you've got the skills and after
Consulting people it seems like the
right policy then I'm all ears so what I
want to talk to you about primarily
you're obviously
highly capable
you appear to be courageous you're
entering a realm of uh Power and you do
so very forthrightly I don't hear you
hedging a lot and the answers you
deliver to questions so I'm really
interested in your perspective your
values and how you think they dovetail
with that office potentially what vision
would you have for the country and
um how might you try to bring us in that
direction
I love it I'm looking forward to the
discussion I've been looking forward to
this for some time actually so
um uh open open for a deep conversation
around that our first sponsor for this
episode is Vivo barefoot shoes made for
feet
everyone should try these shoes most
shoes are made for someone's idea of
feet but not vivos vivos are made by
people with feet who know how to use
them and word is spreading people often
approach us because of the vivos we're
wearing saying that they've heard that
they're good and they are these shoes
are every bit as good as you've heard
here at Dark Horse we love them they are
Beyond comfortable and the tactile
feedback from the surfaces that you're
walking on is amazing they cause no pain
at all because there are no pressure
points forcing your feet into odd
positions they're simply fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt enter Vivo barefoot Vivo
barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and they have everyday wear they're also
a certified B Corp that is pioneering
regenerative business principles and
their Footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild upon
it
go to Vivo barefoot.com and use the code
Darkhorse Vivo 15 to get an exclusive 15
off additionally all new customers get a
100 day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do
that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com and use the code
darkhorsevivo15 at checkout
our final sponsor for this episode is
iherb yep you pronounced the H in iherb
iherb offers the best curated selection
of wellness products and a terrific
value across a variety of categories
including supplements Sports Nutrition
Beauty and baby
baby is a category even if most babies
don't know it
iherb can be and should be your One-Stop
shop for all your health and wellness
needs when iherb approached us we
wondered what makes this supplier
different
turned out we were already ordering from
iherb based on information from
consumerlab.com which tests supplements
to make sure they contain what they say
they contain and nothing else
on iherb site you can search by category
brand or ailment you want help with like
circulatory support or digestive support
and you can further narrow your search
by rating price and dietary restriction
their site is easy convenient and
accurate
for a limited time new customers will
get 22 off their entire order with this
exclusive offer go to iherb.com and use
the promo code Darkhorse to get 22 off
in the winter when the sun is scarce and
we are spending more time inside we take
daily supplements DC zinc and magnesium
and sometimes turmeric
we get it all from iherb everything we
have ordered from iherb has been a snap
and arrived quickly and we know that we
are getting what we paid for
we also know that the products have been
taken care of before they got to us as
all iherb orders are stored and shipped
exclusively by iherb no third-party
Sellers and they ship from a climate
controlled fulfillment center they ship
to over 185 countries and in the U.S
free shipping kicks in on purchases over
20 bucks
so it's time you get your health in
check with iherb our listeners get 22
off their first order when they use the
code Darkhorse at iherb.com that's 22
off your first order at
iherb.com promo code Darkhorse choose
iherb because Wellness matters
all right so let me just ask you about
something that I heard you say
this week which struck me it's a place
where I actually uh I don't need to
convince you but I'm hoping to convince
you for an upgrade of your terminology
and in discussing it I think I think
your values will emerge you were
discussing the question of nationalism
do you want to say what you uh what you
said earlier this week about that
concept
yeah I mean I don't uh I don't exactly
remember what I said earlier this week
versus you know in the past versus today
but uh but with the thesis will be the
same regardless because my beliefs
haven't really changed that much
so
I don't think nationalism has to be a
bad word
and I think especially in the American
context it need not be a bad word
because America is a country founded on
a set of ideals
unlike other nations whose identities
have often been built around a common
ethnicity
or a language or a
you know religion or a monarch we can go
down the list
America's ideals America's identity was
founded around a set of ideals and
Shrine in the Declaration of
Independence codified in the
Constitution
and I think that what's unique about
that
the thing that distinguishes us as human
beings from animals
is the fact that weak and I'm saying
this I know I'm talking to an
evolutionary biologist here so I'm
trying to speak your language but I
might get myself into trouble uh I was a
molecular biologist by background so you
have a higher pay grade than me on this
one but I believe the thing that one of
the things that distinguishes us from
animals
humans as distinctive form of animals is
that we can believe in things
that we can have conviction that we can
be persuaded of things through reason
through appeals to our emotion
through our belief in a narrative
through our ability to espouse ideals
and so if you think about America as a
country founded on a set of ideals that
brought together a divided in many ways
diverse group of people 250 years ago
it's a nation founded on the essence of
what actually makes us distinctively
human
and so the negative connotations around
nationalism is typically an exclusion of
the other where the other is defined as
a fellow human being
here
to me American nationalism is grounded
in an Unapologetic Embrace of the ideals
that thread us that unite us across our
disparate attributes that tug on the
very thing that makes us human beings in
the first place and makes us want to and
ought to respect one another as human
beings too
and so to me that's what American
nationalism is all about is a belief in
those ideals a belief in a nation
founded on those ideals which is a
nation founded on the essence of what
actually defines our Humanity itself
that should cause us not to hide from it
but to embrace it because that might be
our actual Beth best best path to what
you described earlier what did you call
it the unity the thing you worked on
Courage Unity Unity 2020. that is how we
get to National Unity I think is
actually not by
obsessing as I believe we have in in
many ways many ways we've heard in doing
so
in obsessing over our differences often
even skin deep differences we call that
Capital diversity
but instead to
smoke out
what unites us across that diversity and
to me that's what I mean when I call
myself an American nationalist
interesting well you have persuaded me
slightly actually and I'll come back to
why but I want to lay out what I think
is a better
uh use of language and and my feeling uh
as somebody who takes language very
seriously is that at the end of the day
it doesn't really matter what terms we
use for what thing but there needs to be
a term for everything that we need to
refer to we need to be in agreement
about what the term means and the term
has to be precise enough to be useful
and so I I agree with you on that yep I
I've been in this discussion many times
with many of my conservative friends I'm
uh um a liberal I would actually
describe myself as a radical I'm a
reluctant radical because I think
radical change is very dangerous and the
only reason that I would contemplate
radical change is that we don't have a
choice but I do think that's where we
are
but nonetheless I have many conservative
friends and
the term nationalism has been a bit of a
sticking point because to me
there are really two concepts that
because they are similar seeming are
often conflated by people patriotism and
nationalism many conservatives that I
speak to view them as almost the same
thing and I view them as almost
opposites of each other
that patriotism is a willingness to
sacrifice for something and that
something is very often a nation but it
could also be a principle or an idea
and then nationalism I would argue is
the use of that thing uh in a kind of
weaponized form
so in other words I find the two things
juxtaposed in President Kennedy's famous
speech
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
that what your country can do for you is
the Nationalist thread and what you can
do for your country is the Patriotic
thread and so in general when I hear
people invoke nationalism and they are
not uh in an aggressive mindset I really
think that they should be using the term
patriotism so let's what do you hear
there yeah
um so I hear a few things
first I hear is I think we're I'm really
going to enjoy the next couple hours of
my life so this is good
um
that's good for sure
so
I agree with the first thing you said
that often most problems who was it
maybe wittenstein or someone who says
the the most most moral problems are
problems of language
and and I uh
I think I mostly I I think I agree in a
weak form of that hypothesis that's
definitely true uh that many uh problems
of perceived problems of morality uh at
least are partially problems of language
so you know let's you and I could maybe
at the outside of this conversation just
align on the definition so we're not
talking past each other for the next
couple of hours
I think that there's a further than
distinction to be drawn between American
nationalism
and nationalism in the context of a
country
that was not actually founded on ideals
because you're because because my
version of nationalism or American
nationalism
Incorporated your definition of
patriotism which is willingness to
sacrifice for something where that
something isn't ideal that that is
exactly that is exactly why I said that
you had persuaded me was because I heard
in your definition of nationalism the
inclusion of the values that make this
potentially a much more noble weapon not
that it's always been used that yeah
so so it's not even a weapon so it's not
even that I you're kind to say I
persuaded you I just you know maybe it
made it evident that we're talking about
the same thing actually but then there's
a there's a there's a choice that I make
if I'm being really honest about it
right
because I'm saying I could have said
what I wanted to say
in this interview uh if this is the one
you're referring to what I did with a
bunch of editors at Politico when I was
in Washington DC
that was when this came up earlier this
week
I could have said patriotism
or Patriot I say that because I'm a
patriot but I said I'm a nationalist why
did I say that
well it is part of my honest definition
of what it means to be an American
nationalist is it incorporates
at its course not just that it includes
its very essence is a conviction around
the ideals that Define this country
but I use that word for two reasons one
is I want to put a fine point on this
concept of American exceptionalism which
is a belief in the exceptional nature of
the ideals that this country was founded
on
and the fact that this country is
exceptional for being a country that's
founded on ideal so I want to put a fine
point on that but the second point this
is this is the part where I'm being a
little bit honest with you on the game
I'm playing here is
I feel like we're in this lull right now
right we we're in this
hypnotized aimless passage of time in
our country
thinking be living Our Lives as though
we're all a bunch of different
two-legged higher mammals
walk in some common Geographic space
that we call a country doing what our
iPhones told us to do on a given day
programmed by the algorithms that we
thought we were using to program that
were programming us back in reverse that
we need to be waking up out of it a
little bit
we need a little bit of shock therapy
and I think that the path to Unity I'm
going to use your word here Unity runs
through a little bit of discomfort
and so I think that not in a trolling
kind of way but in an honest kind of way
I want to make sure I'm actually getting
there
and I think we only get there by waking
us up out of this hypnotic lull that
takes the status quo for granted so much
so that the status quo will no longer be
the status quo but will be some
perverted form of it by the time we're
done to say that yeah Patriot lands
either not even inside the eardrum or if
it does it goes out the other
but nationalists now I had their
attention for the rest of that meeting
and we had a real conversation about
what it actually means to be an American
with a group of people that otherwise
were ready to check the box and write
some hit pieces on their latest
Republican presidential candidate
all right well uh I am also going to
enjoy the next couple hours
um yeah this is this is fascinating and
I do appreciate what you've said about
the necessity to
um provoke people out of their stupor so
that they actually engage and I have a
whole different uh toolkit surrounding
this but tomorrow so just this may be
used to the extent is useful so to your
point about languages so we can put a
little button on that part of the
conversation if we put this little bow
on it
so then what we can do is take some
words off the shelf like dust them off
like a book in an old bookcase make sure
we do what you and I did level set on
what they actually mean but still use
some residual valence Associated or
attached to that word to perform the
function of waking people up and then we
can still not sacrifice the Precision
that you care about because you and I by
definition just did that at the start of
this conversation but we also awaken the
otherwise people we wouldn't be reaching
if we were just talking about patriotism
yeah this is this is uh exactly
concordant with with my Approach and
basically I would argue that the human
mind uh naturally functions mostly in an
unconscious way and that Consciousness
is the tool that we use for novelty when
we encounter something that we cannot
deal with with automatic processing our
conscious mind gets involved and we
modern folks are unfortunately faced
with a world in which we've got a whole
bunch of totally trivial novelty that
occupies our conscious Minds all the
time I mean even just the ingredient
list on some food you might think to
consume
has a lot of puzzles in it right you
can't process whether or not this is
something you want to put in your mouth
based on what the ingredient list says
because you don't know what most of
those words are so our conscious mind is
sort of being spent on all of these uh
these unresolvable questions but the
correct use of the conscious mind is to
point it towards puzzles that actually
do require this distinctly human
capability and so what you're arguing is
you could have said patriotism maybe
that would even have been the more
accurate term but the point is because
we're so familiar with people invoking
that term in a in a a non-consequential
way we don't even hear it right and then
by saying nationalism saying something
that people have a kind of queasy
feeling about you got their attention
and maybe that was to the to the better
um
I would I do want to go back to your
point about the US and American
exceptionalism because I'm a Believer in
this but I also have a different
framework for it that I think uh maybe
you'll resonate with
so my feeling is that the United States
was
um a a radical experiment in something
and the most important piece of that
experiment is often missed the most
important piece of that experiment is
that all of the Brilliance that is
encoded into the Declaration of
Independence and then as you say
codified in the Constitution
is really about building a nation that
is not ethnically based that is
indifferent to your particular ancestry
and that combines us together so that we
collaborate for the other reason that
Evolution makes people collaborate one
reason is genes that's not a very
interesting reason the really
interesting reason is that by
collaborating with people and being
indifferent to their genetic Heritage we
all come out ahead it's fantastically
productive to participate in
collaboration because there is something
there's profit to be made and so the
founders invented this Melting Pot and
they put together a crude set of rules
for what a Melting Pot would look like
and that idea was so powerful that it
became contagious and so I sort of see
myself now as
a patriot of the West right I'm also a
patriot of the United States but my
feeling is the West are is is composed
of the countries that saw the Brilliance
of this uh way of organizing a society
and adopted it
and I see it as very much now under
threat but in any case
um you know we are in sort of this
modern scenario where
the U.S is this incredibly powerful
nation that also informally
sort of speaks for and steers the west
and we have a responsibility to the
globe in so doing that the Brilliance of
that experiment catches on to all of the
places it hasn't yet reached and that we
complete the job that we finish the you
know we finish the pursuit of the values
that are laid out in our founding
documents and the um historical
amendments that have been made to those
documents by for example the Civil
Rights Movement right that Western
vision is precious and it is our job
effectively to
um
to make the case for it globally
mm-hmm interesting
I am
I want to process that um you're making
me
think uh already it's not something that
happens every day when you're
doing most of the talking like I am
these days
um
so so I I uh I think it's an interesting
Framing and I
I agree with it
the first part but isn't is is the
obvious part is that we're not
ethnically based right so that's not
it's not the commonality of genetics
which makes our country
cohere
that I think alone already poses a basic
challenge right I think you know I just
I just met with the ambassador of
Hungary recently
um you know let's take Italy might even
be a better example this is Georgia
Maloney her
challenge there is I think less daunting
than ours when it talks about Italian
identity what's it based on it is based
on a common genetic heritage
it's based on a Common Language there
are the things that
unite mammals or higher order animals
let's just say higher mammals
the ability to have a common
communication system
and a common genetic lineage that
creates an urge to protect those who are
closest to your kin
that's at the heart of Italian identity
they're swimming in the direction of
biology right but I think the thing
that's evolutionary biology is at least
it spans the animal kingdom
I think the thing that makes America
interesting and hard
and worth pursuing is that
it's a it's a contrarian bet against
that grain now the way you had of of
reaccommodating that in the language of
evolutionary biology and maybe even the
truth of it
was by bringing this argument about
collaboration so we all come out ahead I
want to think about that
it sounds a little bit
um
revisionist to me
in a positive like way a very
optimistically revisionist account
the way I see it is
um maybe a little less optimistically
than that because wouldn't it be neat if
it actually did align with
evolutionarily hardwired instincts of a
different kind for collaboration even if
it wasn't the genetics that'd be
convenient and it would certainly make
my job easier as president and the next
guy's job and thereafter
that much that much more achievable to
deliver National Unity if that's all
there was
but I see the project is a little harder
than that I think it involves
tapping into instincts that
are not and tell me if this
um lands poorly on your ears as an
evolutionary biologist but are are maybe
not the aspects of our nature that
necessarily came from
what you and I would think of as
Evolution but are aspects of us that
were not necessarily
evolved because
We Were Somehow
competitively like it was a competitive
attribute in darwinian selection but is
just a separate attribute of humanity
which sometimes runs against our
interests right the ability to make a
sacrifice
so you're part of your definition of
patriotism
I think you're gonna have to you know
this gets into whole darwinian debates
you know assert your own conclusion many
times over in order to say that that was
evolutionarily hardwired and you know
I'm sure you could come up for the
account for it and part of that account
is going to be this group theory of
being in the interest of the whole group
and that's why we collaborate companies
are all come out ahead if we actually
you know equally make the sacrifice it's
like this thought experiment that cont
had about the fishermen of why everyone
doesn't overfish is because they're
making a short-term sacrifice for
themselves that ultimately work to the
benefit of the whole
but that's not the way like I just see
that part of our human nature that's the
part of our human nature that I see is
endowed by our creator
and it is in us to call out the what
what Lincoln might have referred to as
the better angels of our of our nature
which I'm not sure came to us from
Evolution maybe did maybe it didn't it
did come to Revolution Evolution was the
tool that somebody else maybe we'll call
him God put in US
uh but anyway I think that makes the job
a little bit harder because we're
actually on my account of it running
against the grain of otherwise
evolutionary odds that are stacked
against us
all right well we now are squarely in my
home turf and I believe I have some very
good news for you that just comes with a
bitter pill right so the bigger pill is
kind of you're intuiting it as a bigger
part of the story than I think it is
let me just put it to you this way there
are two evolutionary reasons to
collaborate
one of them is jeans and the other is
The Profit produced by reciprocity
my argument the one I laid out before is
that the reciprocity version of
collaboration is way more Dynamic and
Powerful
but it is also fragile
right so when we humans collaborate
because it makes sense to and we are
indifferent to our genetic relatedness
or lack of it
we produce wonderful things and in fact
it is not an accident in my opinion that
the strange experiment that the founders
built in the United States also is
responsible for a huge fraction of the
most important inventions that have ever
been produced on earth right we're
talking about computers we're talking
about airplanes right the the list of
things that Americans did because they
were more indifferent to race than they
than any previous civilization is
staggering and so that is what happens
when you collaborate uh because
reciprocity is productive rather than
because you're genetically related but
the problem is that it is much easier
for evolution to stabilize that
collaboration when times are good when
you have growth right and when growth
fails we break back down into those
tribal alliances that are founded on
something more durable and so my fear is
that the brilliant experiment that did
take place in the west is now faltering
because we have run up against
hard limits or at least a long dry spell
in our ability to produce growth and so
that this is actually a biological
flip-flop between two different
biological modes of collaborating
and I will just insert one more thing
there in light of what you said you you
detected something exactly right
which is that the competition is the
driver and that led you to believe that
possibly collaborating uh the
reciprocity issue was maybe less
biological and that we need to resist
biological urges that's not right the
fact is we evolved to collaborate in
order to compete we collaborate to
compete so it's not an invalidation of
of uh competition it's a type of
competition
so uh the bitter pill is that we Face
the breakdown of our very dynamic system
our very unique and proven system in the
west the fairest civilization I would
argue that has ever existed we Face the
breakdown of it into something uh more
familiar from history far less Fair far
less Dynamic and far less capable
mm-hmm
for the purpose of this discussion are
you okay if we just stick to America
versus the West sure okay just I know it
doesn't change your thesis it um
I get annoyed I I'll be annoyingly
distracted if we say keep saying Western
Civilization because there's some
exceptions there and just talk about it
no I'm I'm happy with that I just I just
I I I am uh always troubled in the other
direction right when we talk as if
America is bigger than it is when in
fact it is sort of bigger than it is
because it caught on
yeah yeah so I know I know you missed
everything you said you wouldn't
disagree with that but it would yeah
if we just talked about America so but
back to the more interesting part of
what you were saying so
you know the the funny thing about
America and this is just like you know
um
not a particularly deep Point other than
a coincidence of history but it's kind
of interesting is that 1776 was actually
the year of both
the Declaration of Independence
and The Wealth of Nations sort of
interesting right and so so there's
something about American identity and
the last part of what you said really
struck a chord with me right evolved
to collaborate to compete right is
there's there's both elements woven into
it's like the mother and the father of
America the collaboration and the
competition
democracy and capitalism
individualism and unity
the Declaration of Independence and The
Wealth of Nations it's it's a funny
thing in America that that uh
both of them are our parents
and then a big part of my work over the
last
several years before the presidency was
actually sometimes when the parents run
roughshod over each other you have to
keep them apart
that's what stakeholder capitalism
esgism is all about actually is
is the merger of the two impulses or the
two I guess we could call them impulses
um yeah disastrous merger yeah it's the
disastrous merger where you you are left
with neither collaboration nor
competition but some perverse form of
both and then this is the dissolution of
power between the state and the private
sector that then creates this is a
different context a great a greater
threat to American identity and liberty
and prosperity than if they were kept
apart but that's getting into my land
um we can go there if you want but more
interested in your land
um you know but that's that's
interesting so I I actually actually buy
your I actually buy your account and I
think that that makes me more optimistic
about what's possible for the
continuation in the future of our
experiment because it points Us in the
direction of some things that I think we
can deliver that will help get us there
I mean I actually am the the pro-growth
candidate in this race
I think I think it does get to a bit of
a mystery where if you if you believe
what I do
about growth which is that most of our
obstacles to growth at least in America
right now
were
self-inflicted but that's not a dour
diagnosis this actually should be
uplifting because it means that we can
self-liberate from those restraints
you know I mean I constraints on
American energy drill Frack burn coal
Embrace nuclear number one input to
growth number two put people back to
work how do you want to do that well
stop paying them to stay at home to
start it's the number one obstacle to
the growth of any business is is they
can't hire people right now and we could
I could go on reform in the Federal
Reserve uh I've written extensively
about that which we can get into if you
if you really want to
get ready for bed but uh but or some
people like this stuff and I can go into
it but but my administrative state but
then we we know what we can do
to restore those conditions of growth
against the backdrop of which it's much
easier for as you said Evolution to
stabilize
the you know just just to provide
stability to that form of collaboration
which is otherwise tenuous and against
the backdrop conditions of Plenty it
becomes that much easier to do
um so I'm not one of these pro-growth
people that believes that's the entirety
of the story I do think that there's an
identity vacuum
that is Upstream of our
stagnation and growth that has to be
independently addressed in our country
it's a big part of what I'm stepping up
to do in this race but I agree with you
that a high growth environment certainly
greases the wheels and opens the heart
to a vision of identity that's healthy
if you if you're actually delivering
growth and so tangibly I think that's
something I'm going to do as an
ex-president but but I don't think it's
the entirety of the story where there's
a deeper void of purpose and meaning in
the American soul that we still need to
fill if we want to go the distance of
bequeathing the experiment to the Next
Generation
um
agreed there's a whole Rabbit Hole to go
down there with respect to growth what
it is where it comes from and what is
actually realistic with respect to
stabilizing it one of my big concerns
would be that if you build a system that
requires growth in order for people to
get along then you're setting it up for
failure and so there's a there's a
hazard there but before we get there I
want to point out you had a list of
what I call the dynamic tensions right
um between uh what was it uh democracy
and capitalism anyway you had a list of
these things and there's one of them
that I think is missing from the list
which I find
um vitally important and highly relevant
to the conversation that you and I are
having here which is the tension between
right and left
and my argument for this would be
that
these things are
both
fundamentally necessary the dynamic
tension between right and left is the
magic ingredient that makes our system
work and I fear anybody on either side
who views their side as correct and
would like to dispense with the other
right because folks on the left who do
not have honorable Partners on the right
they their minds run away with them and
they try to solve all kinds of problems
that are maybe much harder to solve than
they realize and they create a landscape
of unintended consequences that's a
disaster right and folks on the right
who think they can dispense with the
progressive impulse actually will
stagnate because they're so busy
conserving things that work they miss
opportunity after opportunity to
actually get somewhere new and so it is
base basically you you need honorable
conservatives and honorable liberals to
partner in the navigation each holding
the other back from its worst impulses
so anyway this is this theme has become
an important one in my life because my
own trajectory although as I I said I'm
very much of the left
I don't really get along with people on
the left at the moment most of my
friends are on the right
um in part because it is the
preservation and augmentation of the
American experiment that animates us
both right we have different roles to
play in it but but it is really a
question of whether or not you want to
see that thing uh continue and flourish
or not
um so anyway not surprising to me that
you and I would have a very rich
conversation yeah I think um
I look at that Dynamic tension between
the right and left in a similar way but
you know one of competition sort of
pushing each
side to be the best version of itself
I think that there are certain
personality types that are naturally
drawn
through the way that they're wired to be
of the left and certain personality
types just the innate attributes I mean
I've got two sons you were talking
before and you've got two kids too
I I promise you I I would like to think
we haven't treated our two sons any
differently they're just different
people right they just come differently
they show up you know part of it feels
just like they are who they are and they
don't have political views yet they're
super young but
there's certain backdrop conditions that
open your heart and mind to
be inclined in a certain way at least
adjusted for certain periods of your
life that part of its persuasion but
part of it's the natural
psychological inclinations personality
attributes that you have I think that
there's a certain form of free-form
creativity unstructured creativity that
probably all else equal disposes someone
to be on the left
I think that there's probably some form
of discipline or
you know obsessive quality to discipline
that
some of that's hardwired personality
attributes that natively disposes
someone to be on the right if these can
a lot of attributes affect this but
anyway I think that
each one of those
people who have such personality
attributes let's just take right and
left out of it now right in a
functioning Society in a society that's
evolved to collaborate to compete to use
your earlier language there's a role for
each side part of the collaboration is
the competition of pushing each one to
be the best version of him or herself
and then I think we get complicated
where
let's just look inside I mean there are
elements of each of that within me as a
person right there's a part of me that
is disciplined
you know with obsessive often even
compulsive Tendencies to channel that
discipline and there's a part of me that
is
totally free spirit and unconstrained
and so it's not even that it resides
within within those individual people
but I think there's like an element of
if we're then to use that label for
right and left of the right and left
that resides within each of us too and
so that's collaboration and competition
within different parts of our own Spirit
within ourselves as a person
and then and then certainly there's the
version of that amongst ourselves as
people too so I think about it more that
way than in terms of just right and left
partly because to your earlier Point
what do those words even mean right now
right I think we Define nationalism in
Patriots as a much more easily than you
and I would be able to distinguish right
and left right now in the current
landscape I think that's what makes it
so interesting to be a politician I
sometimes cringe at that term right now
because I've been one for all of three
and a half months but
that's what makes it so interesting and
exciting to be a politician in a time
when those definitions are themselves up
for grabs but uh but anyway I I I agree
with you that whatever they are there's
a role for both
attributes which I think of as more than
even political views both sets of
Personality attributes that push us to
be the best version of ourselves
individually and as a whole
yeah I uh quite resonate with that and I
also think that this particular moment
in history is one
where
the traditional distinction between
right and left or blue and red
it couldn't possibly matter less
I agree with you I say this to hardcore
conservative audiences all the time
forget the Republican versus Democrat
labeling it's actually kind of a
projection it's a farce
I think we live in more of a 1776 moment
where we need to revive
what it actually means to be an American
let's ask that question get it on the
table it's part of why you entered
Article 5 Convention of States fine I
won't get in the way of that let's have
a conversation about what it means to be
an American
I'm I'm uh you know people use the word
America First and they say It's
associated with Trump or whatever no to
me it's associated with George
Washington I'm a George Washington
America First conservative let's talk
let's have the George Washington
conversation
totally
um you know this is in some ways the the
story of my life for the last six years
where I'm sure you don't know the story
but
um my wife and I were
spectacularly ejected from the left
um by virtue of us running up against a
very uh colorful and dramatic version of
the diversity equity and inclusion
movement in our roles as professors and
so
anyway you know we had lived in the most
liberal of environments in the in the
blue sense of it and then suddenly we
were demonized as members of the right
which was based on nothing at all but
nonetheless the
the number of people I have now seen
ejected from the left who are then
demonized as on the right who function
as a kind of another left in Exile
widely misunderstood
um you know I mean Bobby Kennedy junior
is one of these people right he's
absolutely triggered an allergic
reaction on the blue team but when you
talk to him his values are you know what
the Democratic party used to stand for
so it's not surprising
for me to see him sit down and have a
productive conversation with Tucker
Carlson as I've also Done Right the
point of any of us who are Patriots
first are meeting in the middle because
that's where you meet even if it's not
where we come from right we're we're as
you say it's a 1776 moment and the
question is is this idea important
enough for us to actually
die on that Hill not to kind of point on
it no the the I mean well it was it's a
phraseology so you're embracing the the
thought experiment here
you know the only thing I would say is
I just wonder whether it might be more
productive
if we even just for a little while like
as in then maybe the next couple of
years
let's just let go of
the label right and left for a little
bit right it sort of sort of actually I
think
oftentimes it's useful to have a sense
of ordering you have a scatter plot it's
still useful to draw the line that runs
through the scatter plot
sometimes like once in a while it's just
useful to just look at the scatter plot
as a scatter plot without bothering to
dry the fit draw the fit line and I do
feel like part of what I mean when I say
it's a 1776 moment is it's one of those
moments where
don't drive don't draw the fit line just
just look at the scatter plot and let's
let's talk about where each of the dots
fall without worrying whether or not
they align with the line
and that's the way I kind of view this
presidential race I mean many of the
things I'm saying are
certainly aligned with Reagan values
some of them are aligned with post
Reagan Trump values and some of them are
aligned with libertarian values some of
them are aligned with
you know not heretofore pre-existing
nationalistic values some of them are
George Washington America First
non-interventionist values my position
on Ukraine has earned me I think a lot
of you know the person has the most
similar position to me on Ukraine is
actually RFK and you know and I think
I'm interested in diving in on some of
the details because I've gone into level
of detail on this that I'd love to see
whether he agrees with or not but
anyway the the point is
we might be better served not even using
that lexicon for a little while let the
dust settle and what we might find is is
let's say we have to put people in two
camps again because we have a two-party
system we might be it might just look
very different in terms of what's left
and reordered about it and I think
that'll be a good thing for us actually
not a bad thing okay 1776 moment we
didn't have two parties in 1776. yep
took about eight years it didn't take
long but it took about eight years in
to to let that dust sort of settle the
election of 1800
um you know started that kicked that
process off for us
but I think that if we're really going
1776 on this or 1789 or 1792 really
setting the whole thing in motion for
two terms
let's try that for a little bit and I
think that that's actually probably the
moment that we live in right now
well I I agree with you which brings us
to a topic uh
I feel it's going to be awkward but I
also uh detect your your openness and
your flexibility to discuss anything
which I really appreciate
um you know the one thing about
you and it isn't you but the one thing
about you as you arrive uh in my field
of awareness that troubles me is that
you're vying for the nomination of the
Republican party and mind you this has
nothing to do with the Republican party
I would say at the moment the Republican
Party
um has more patriotism to it than the
Democratic party does and I'm you know
I'm a lifelong Democrat I'm still a
Democrat
um but I think my party is unrescuable
um but I in some sense I wonder
a what do you think the democ the
Republican Party structure would think
of your candidacy I'm not asking about
the rank and file Republicans right
that's up to them but the structure that
actually subtly adjusts who can
um Ascend to high office what does it
think of you and mind you let me just
say you can tell me if I misunderstand
your party
but I don't think it wanted Trump I
think no it did not Trump beat it at its
own game
but what do you think it thinks of you I
think it uh
it'll have similar reactions to me that
it had to Trump in 2015 actually
sort of anaphylactic reaction but it
looks different I look different than
Trump and the party looks different
because it's Trump influenced now yep so
so what I see going on is the first
conversation I've had
um you know about this it's only
something I've really started to kind of
perceive more recently
and it's interesting it's kind of fun to
watch
is that the Republican party now what's
going on is
Trump has itself become part of the new
DNA of the Republican party I mean even
the rank and file but also the party
structure itself in part though part of
that has a latent anaphylactic reaction
to him still which is the part that then
releases its pent-up energy into this
thing they call DeSantis right now but I
think that that's really this thing
known as DeSantis is really just a
manifestation of that pent-up energy
that's found itself uh you know
for the moment boying one man
but I think that's a symbol of a deeper
undercurrent and attention there but the
thing that I think that is going on in
the party is they've recognized that
okay The Establishment needs to
wrap itself in the mantle of being
anti-establishment
and so that kind of works because it
tricks some of the people in the rank
and file or on the ground level in the
Grassroots who are in their bones
anti-establishment and sort of get
some of them not most I think most of
them have a good radar for this but some
temporarily will be drawn in to say yes
that anti-establishment is us only to be
joining
really uh the
the traditional establishment and so
that's the funny thing going on in the
Republican party right now
is there's this game of Manufacturing
the anti-establishment
Aura yep but the thing on the inside of
it is like about his establishment as it
gets and I think that there is there are
a couple candidates one in particular
Who are the
manifestation of that in the Republican
party right now
um
I think there's an element of it that's
true for Trump but Trump's not the one
that I mean uh I think it's mostly
you know but but it's Two Front Runners
really right now and I think that that
Dynamic is is interesting it's
fascinating I think that the
the bass you know if you will you know
are are I consider myself part of it
will
I think has a pretty good Sixth Sense
and will soon if not already
see through that but it is a little bit
of a decoy that's been thrown into the
system the amounts of gobs of money used
to sort of buy up social media
influencers or whatever to make
the AstroTurf seam Grassroots in the
sticking it to the man where the man is
like you know create the boogeyman of of
the Biden radical left or whatever is
really just a form of an establishment
wearing an anti-establishment veneer
when in fact I think the uh
the the party the I predict that's part
of the reason I'm in this is I think
that people will be able to tell the
difference and
people will vote for the
the antigen over the antibody uh and I
think that Trump was the antigen in 2015
and
I think in 2023
I'm already proving to be the antigen to
that establishment in the Republican
Party by the way itself and there's a
very specific they're closing ranks in a
certain way around
uh you know a certain
puppet of that establishment on the
Democratic side that's Biden I think
there's emerging version of that in the
Republican party too but uh but I think
that that is already beginning to have
an anaphylactic reaction to me
well
um
I'll give you some advice you didn't ask
for
I'll tell you do you think the
electorate is growing wise to this game
in both of our major political parties I
think so the openness to something that
did not come in a familiar package
uh has never been higher and I believe
it is in fact higher at this moment
enough to carry the day so I don't know
if you're
trajectory requires you to go through
the motions of attempting to get the
Republican nomination and then
if you fail to get it which uh through
no fault of yours I expect is the likely
outcome because of the structure
um that then you will be placed in the
awkward position of
uh if you decide
to continue running anyway that you will
be accused of all kinds of spoilerism
and that sort of thing but anyway I
would encourage
you to look at what's happening on both
sides of the aisle and recognize that
the American public does not seem to be
falling for it this time right there is
a game that is played in the U.S that
involves using the primaries to limit
the options to only those things that
are palatable to what you're calling the
establishment
and that trick has been played on us so
many times that
people are ready to think outside the
box
the chessboard has changed radically CNN
doesn't hold the kind of sway it once
did you know and Joe Rogan and Tucker
Carlson and various other folks outside
of that structure now have a tremendous
amount of influence and a tremendous
amount of openness to
um to breaking through the traditional
boundaries so anyway I would just
encourage you to think about whether or
not
the way that this used to be done has to
be the way that it's done this time I
mean even your own party was forged by
you know forged in such an Insurgency
yeah I think so I mean I think I'm I'm
less of like uh I'm no fan of the
two-party system but I'm not one of
these like rabid opponents to it and go
to you know ranked Choice voting system
that's the solution it's process
I actually think a lot of the people who
find their way into saying those things
are actually not not as you yourself but
but I see this in like Silicon Valley or
otherwise it sort of sort of cop out
where it's the safe way for them to vent
their frustration at the substance but
to then pin it to proceduralism that
makes it less controversial way for them
to vent the thing on the substance
and so the way I look at is a little bit
different where like take a place like
India which has a not not a two-party
system but a multi-party system
but it's like a totally frustratingly
broken electoral process as well like
local politicians are literally in the
multi-party system you only need to get
to 26 of the vote often to win usually
deprive enough people to win I mean
literally they give out like these old
televisions to Like Houses many of which
still don't have televisions and they're
like here's a TV exchange that for your
vote multi-party system this is a
multi-party system can exist without
anchoring to principle but I think the
mirror image of that is I think it is
entirely possible for a two-party system
to exist where the people who are
participating in it are still Guided by
principle rather than by tropes that are
vestiges of partisanship
and so I think both are possible right
and so what I'm looking at is the
Republican Party
is a vehicle for advancing what I kind
of call this American nationalist
in the sense that you would call Patriot
Pro patriotic movement
and I'm using that as vehicle to advance
that agenda
but I think whether or not I was doing
it
through the Republican party or in the
context of a outside of two-party system
in some other alternative state of the
world
like the procedure matters less and what
matters more is are the leaders who are
moving and galvanizing the minds and
hearts of Voters doing what they're
doing grounded on principles or are they
hollowed out husks going through emotion
like a billiard ball that rolls in
whatever Direction it's hit as opposed
to asking why we're aiming to hit the
billiard ball in a given Direction in
the first place
and so anyway that's a long way of
saying I
I have my frustrations with the
primary system as it exists and then the
general election but I don't want to pin
all of the blame on that I think the
blame goes deeper for us as a citizenry
to look ourselves in the mirror and ask
ourselves are we engaged as Citizens
based on conviction of principle or is
it some other hollowed out husk process
that has been corrupted in many ways and
both both parties are badly corrupt by
the influence of money in politics and
the Republican party I can't I probably
couldn't tell you which one was worse
they're competing both are pretty bad I
think right now maybe the Democratic
like literally the second the Democratic
party might be worse but let's see by
the end of this race the Republican
Party hasn't outmatched them uh maybe it
will but
I think that I think that we should
focus on the substance rather than just
the proceduralism of the two-party
system maybe the two-party system would
be just fine if there wasn't such a
corrupting influence of money on both
existing parties which then made created
a duopoly that was often controlled by
the same class that was pulling both
parties as the string of it really
wasn't a duopoly it was a monopoly
disguises duopoly which is the big part
of what I think is going on in the
country as it pertains to the donor
class in America as well
yeah I agree with this quite a bit I
mean I don't
I don't care how the right people Ascend
to the office I care whether the office
retains the power for them to be useful
and whether the values that they carry
there are ones that are liable to
advance
um the ball in the direction that I
think makes sense my concern though is
exactly the one you raise which is that
because
both parties
are now
uh thinly disguised influence peddling
operations
that they effectively
extract a kind of control over
candidates that they allow to ascend so
that by the time you get to the office
you either have lost the instinct to do
the right thing or you have become so
constrained so encumbered by the donors
who have put you in a position to do it
that you don't do the right thing and so
anyway my you know you're interesting to
me in part because you have been a
politician for only what is it three
months did you say yeah three and a half
price so the point is you didn't come
from this system so you're not yet of
this system and my point is actually
this is the moment I mean look if the if
the Republican Party
responded to the current moment with the
the proper seriousness
right if it responded and said hey
actually this is an emergency and this
is not a moment for the donor class to
be controlling anything because we have
to save the nation right I would listen
but I don't hear that from it right
I hear Politics as Usual from both
parties I do think at the moment the the
Democratic party has become
um
somewhat more deeply infected by this
thing you know I I see the Republican
party as more or less having uh
innovated the the influence peddling
game not that the Democratic party was
free of this there was plenty of machine
politics but the Democratic party used
to at least
in some regard retain political power by
serving the interests of working
Americans right
and yes the labor unions had plenty of
corruption and all that but nonetheless
it was at some level the party of the
working class and the Republicans were
the party of management and then the
Clinton Administration decided to muscle
in on the Republicans uh action and
suddenly we had no party that
represented working people right and I
see that as a a disastrous moment in
American history but at this point I
it's not that the two it's not the two
parties is itself the problem
I can live with two parties that's what
I'm saying yep but I don't know about
these parties I would want one exactly
right and so to me honestly it's going
to be an interesting experiment right
where
here's my commitment
I'm going to speak truth
at every step of the way
and maybe that'll lead to electoral
success
and maybe it won't
and I I'm fine with the outcome where it
doesn't lead to electoral success my
mission here if I'm doing my job and
running this campaign well
is that by the end of it there's no way
it could happen in the beginning of it
but by the end of it everyone will know
every voter will know
who I am
and what I believe
and if I don't get elected
based on that
that's fine I'm at peace with that my
deeper insecurity is that the process is
so broken that
even if I approach it that way there's
no way actually voters will know who I
am or what I believe
because it will have been distorted
largely by the influence and I can't
believe these words are coming out of my
mouth because like 15 years ago
you know I was not skeptical of these
things in the same way that I am now
having seen it but will be distorted by
money actually
the image that
I've seen it I mean you see it every day
on the internet right you know I think
the the paid
Distortion of the scales of discourse
is
you know will create a projection that
I'm not at all confident that
maybe I'll get elected and people don't
know exactly what I believe and maybe I
won't get elected because people don't
know who I am or what I believe but but
in my ideal state of the world the
process is working well if
they know who I am and what I believe
and in possession of that
they decide to make their own decision
and so here's the part that's in my
control there's two things that can
create that Distortion that they don't
know who I am or what I believe one is
me trying to say
what I think people want to hear
even though it's not actually what I
believe that's one way and I think it's
a way that most candidates actually fall
into the Trap of
ending up with the result where people
don't know who they are what they
believe I won't do that because I'm
fully prepared to lose
this election uh you know they don't my
my sense
I'll probably experience some part of me
that'll experience of relief if that day
comes to pass
but actually
the other way that it could happen is
just that that's the way the broken
system already works is that it creates
this
artificial projection even though I'm
saying all the things that I believe to
be true at every step of the way and I'm
kind of seeing this play out in the
early phases of this campaign already
that the distortions introduced by money
into the process
will prevent voters from knowing that
anyway
and that's the regrettable part and the
part that's not going to be in my
control
but here but but I'm going to stick to a
belief in doing what is in my control
I'll speak truth at least at least show
what my true convictions are
and
trust that
I'll leave the rest to a higher power
they could the higher power means here
in the literal sense the higher power of
the voters to be able to sort that out
for themselves and and make the bet that
you suggest that we think we can make
which is that people have wisened up to
a little bit
and an electorate that is prepared to
cut through the projections that they're
served and still be able to sort out for
themselves
making the choice they want to make
um that sounds great I do think we can
look a couple steps down the road and uh
maybe you're right and this is doable
through your party if it's not if your
party
um
looks at your Independence and Views it
as hostile to its business plan mind you
it shouldn't have one but if it does and
it views you as hostile to it then at
the point that it tells you that you are
um obligated to step aside and endorse
whoever it is that ascends
I would suggest that you think very
carefully about whether that is in fact
consistent with your values and uh
basically tell them to go screw
themselves in uh
no uncertain terms because
we Americans do deserve candidates
who take our interests seriously and if
those candidates cannot rise through our
parties then they must rise outside of
them and that's the natural order of
things and again I I would think the
Republican party which began with you
know
Lincoln's Insurgency
uh would have to understand and accept
that so anyway that's a long way down
the road before we even find out what's
going to happen and I I uh I hope you
your optimistic view of your party is
closer to accurate than my
um uh admittedly cynical View
I uh I do too
and and we'll find out in the next year
but I I am
you know but I have this I have this
weird confidence and it is weird right
you look at the numbers but my my gut
instinct though
is that
like in my bones I just believe that
this is good this is going to be the
winning strategy of
speaking truth without attachment to the
result might actually be the best path
to actually get to the result and we'll
find out
yeah we'll find out it's the one I'm
trying great well I'm I'm glad to hear
that uh can I ask you about another even
potentially more delicate topic sure all
right
um I was doing a little research and I
was
um
let's say completely heartbroken to
discover uh your name in close proximity
to the world economic forum and then I
was heartened to discover that that
connection might not actually be
um what it appeared to be would you
what the hell is going on there yes so
the funny so so it's fascinating so
there's the bunch line is there's no
connection
uh but the complicating part is they
projected a connection
and it in in the extent to which this
was intentional
versus as they're framing it accidental
or inadvertent
is interesting to me it says accents
about as accidental as when LinkedIn
two weeks ago censored me they locked my
account I thought it was some technical
glitch on like our team's part I got a
bunch of text messages one day
and uh believe me I would come back to
the world economic Forum but it's the
analogy is is striking here Microsoft
owned LinkedIn
I get a bunch of text messages people
who say they follow my content on
LinkedIn they're like oh I can't see it
anymore uh did you leave LinkedIn I was
like I don't think so that's my social
media team I don't I approve the videos
in the text but I don't know who puts
what where
so anyway they said that oh actually
LinkedIn seems to have locked your
account I said well that must be some
kind of glitch figured out why we get an
email back and it lays out here are the
reasons why here are some videos you
posted one was about the links between
Biden and China and then the other two
are about my views on climate policy one
of which said that if the climate cult
as I called it had to do with the
climate then we'd be worrying about
carbon emissions from places like Russia
and China and the second was that fossil
fuels are a precondition for human
Prosperity right it's a requirement for
human Prosperity so he said that these
three statements violated their policies
so we we went back and said what's
inaccurate about these statements
actually provided evidence to support
them they're either opinions or opinions
grounded in facts what's false they said
the Double Downs that this violates our
policies on hate speech misinformation
and violence so that's the email
exchange at which point I just took the
emails and posted them on Twitter which
then prompted media inquiries to
LinkedIn and Microsoft which then caused
them to come back and say no no this was
and their word not mine error
right when a tech company says it makes
an error makes it sound like it was like
that technical glitch this is not a
human an error or a human error in the
sense if you think of an error it was a
bad judgment that they made to censor
based on Viewpoint so that was that was
LinkedIn that's what remind that's what
I'm reminded of when I see the world
economic Forum now suggesting that it
was just an error
that they didn't remove my name from
their list of young global leaders so
what happened
was that I get a call
from some guy that says hey you know
you're going to be invited to join the
world economic forum's young global
leaders
I said I respectfully decline I don't
know if you noticed the title of my
first book woke Inc or the nature of the
op-eds that I've written in the Wall
Street Journal over the last year
arguing against
stakeholder capitalism the very
philosophy emerging state power and
corporate power pervade from that and
offices of Davos by people like Cloud
Schwab but I respectfully decline to the
contrary if you actually want to have an
open public debate on our different
perspectives I'd engage you but thank
you very much
number of months later I get I wake up
again to a slew of it always happens
this way congratulatory text messages
this time saying congrats on being named
to the world economic forum and the guy
told me I called him up I said
this is incorrect I don't know what was
unclear about this emails that Center to
that effect too
I don't believe I was unclear with you
but I respectfully declined and continue
to decline this to it she says no no you
don't understand
you are in a group where you're going to
be able to meet the billionaires around
the world that might be able to help you
Mark Zuckerberg others gave me a full
list of the names of people have been
included I said I declined so I mailed
them I said I want my name removed they
said okay
months passed turns out my name isn't
removed other people keep flagging it
for me now I'm writing more about the
topics I've been writing about crusading
against DSG in the US and people are
saying wait a minute
why is your name showing up on this I'll
see that pop up on Twitter and then I
said I asked to be removed so some guy
says well then why haven't they removed
you so on Twitter they tagged the world
economic Forum I said it's false they
said oh no we apologize we're moving it
still don't remove you at this point I I
can't really tell whether it's
incompetence or something intentional
about this
and so it proceeds so far that people
like you
experience profound disappointment at
this and now I'm a presidential
candidate yep so I said you know what
let's let's just make sure they don't do
this again to anybody else there's good
evidence they did it to Elon Musk and to
you know Peter Thiel apparently was
showing up on one of their lists
Mark and the reason I believe some of
these people may have voluntarily you
know been fine with it and weren't
thinking about it but in any case in my
case I was thinking about it and I said
I didn't want to be included so I sued
them and so I currently am in litigation
against the world economic forum
holding them accountable for exactly
what they did lied it was a lie yep and
so my demand I'm not in this for money I
don't want to make money off of this I'm
open to if it's okay but but that's not
my objective
my objective is I I I'm going to demand
a few things from them
a firm apology
a firm acknowledgment of the facts and
most importantly a firm commitment that
they will not do that to somebody again
in the future and and I've been I've
grown to it's a habit of so far it's
working out okay is I like going to the
other side's turf holding my line and
winning
I don't appreciate just showing up and
making a point we have to actually
deliver the win my exchange that's why I
show up on the set with Don Lemon at CNN
or check Todd on NBC a lot of my fellow
contenders in this Republican race it's
it's a little disappointing actually
some of them you know Rhonda Santa says
he won't talk to NBC News because
they're not nice to him well
last time I checked we're volunteering
to see who serves the country sitting
across the table from Xi Jinping so if
you can't sit across the table from
Chuck Todd that should raise some
questions about your Fitness to sit
across the table from Xi Jinping or some
of them will say they won't go to
college campuses unless the questions
are pre-screened well it's easy to
preach about cancel culture and Free
Speech to your own tribe when you're not
willing to practice what you preach and
then many of those same people by the
way are the ones who are wrapping
themselves in that anti-establishment
veneer
which is which is very funny because
it's just an establishment core with an
anti-establishment AstroTurf rapper
around it but my view is we just have to
practice what we preach I'll go to the
other side's Turf left right doesn't
matter show up and win
and that's what I'm doing with the world
economic Forum now we're in litigation
as we speak great well you say uh you're
not in it for the money I would uh
encourage you
um to the extent that you can win a
victory and bleed that organization
drive please do it on behalf of the
citizens of planet Earth
um and you know if you have to give the
money to charity so be it but um but
anyway yes they are a a blight on
Humanity to be certain
uh not surprising to me at all that they
I mean what an interesting tactic to
defame you by associating you with them
without your consent I mean that is an
amazing strategy it's a great way to
take the legs out from one of your
greatest threats and competitors right
absolutely so what was the word you used
to I would go in the beginning I was
taking notes as you were talking here um
what were the three things that you you
said um
courage courageous capable Patriot
Patriot okay so Patriot so let's go back
to 1776 right this is actually what the
American Revolution was fought over
is the vision of the world economic
Forum today
it's a vision that some Monarch on the
other side of the Atlantic gets to
govern
the most important questions of how
citizens live their lives
the American Revolution was fought to do
one thing it was to say that we the
people
decide how we sort out our differences
on climate change on racial Justice on
whatever we the people decide what the
right answers are to those questions
through a system where every
individual's voice and vote counts
equally
as a citizen that I'm a citizen of this
nation the United States of America not
some nebulous Global citizen pledging
allegiance to some sort of
corporatocratic autocracy disguised in
the mantle of benevolence
and yet we thought we settled that in
1776 and now that
ugly monster rears its head again and we
have to be alert to it
call it our version of wokeness being
awake to the threats posed by an
invisible autocratic class
that old world European view that no no
the people the citizenry cannot be
trusted to sort these questions out for
themselves it has to be sorted out in
the back of Palace Halls right in the
back of the corner office of BlackRock
on Park Avenue or the Mountaintop of
Davos at the annual meeting of the world
economic Forum that is what's at issue
and I reject that Vision absolutely I
think that Republicans and Democrats
alike should stand up to say that we'll
disagree like hell but it's going to be
us that settle this question
through our process not through some
form of monarchic intervention
absolutely the the founders settled this
question on our behalf and they did so
correctly and they left these
authoritarians with one legitimate tool
and that is to persuade us if they can't
persuade us they don't get to do it and
they do not accept that and it is
shocking to me that their refusal to
accept it matters it is in fact evidence
of the corruption not only of the
American system but of the global system
that we actually have to worry that they
will impose their obnoxious Vision on us
even though it is written in our
founding documents that we have a right
to Simply say no right that is an
amazing fact that that is the piece of
history that we live in and yet here we
clearly are
here we clearly are that's right
so well I think I'm optimistic
um
not not blindly optimistic but
optimistic that through
a modern Declaration of Independence a
modern Revival of that 1776 moment a
modern
suspension of the drudgery of
bipartisan
corruption or
haggle or or division or whatever you
want to call it part I think the
corruption in the division are two sides
of the same coin
I'm optimistic that we can cut through
that new threat to Liberty in the way
that we did back in 1776 and that's
honestly what I'm running the lead
um I absolutely believe that we can
um I don't know
have you run into something called The
Hidden tribes report
I have not the hidden tribes report is a
fascinating document that reveals that
the American populace
overwhelmingly agrees on most issues
even the issues that we are famously not
supposed to agree on and that there are
basically two fringes which push us
around and prevent us from having the
discussion we should have but that there
is something that the hidden tribes
report called the exhausted middle which
is all those of us who agree on the
basic principles
and uh would if not for this artificial
division be able to to navigate these
these nuances and what I hear you saying
appeals very strongly to that exhausted
middle What I Hear Bobby Kennedy saying
middle and so I think you know I
resonate with your optimism about our
ability to get through this in fact I
think the path to get through it is more
straightforward than we realize but the
mechanism to get us on that path is
going to involve
behaving in ways that are
counter-intuitive right I think
counterintuitive is right I mean Brett
the one that we're I don't think we I
suspect we don't disagree but I phrase
it really differently is I don't talk
about the middle because that
presupposes a single axis to pull system
and I just don't think that's where we
are right now I think it's the scatter
plot well let's not even draw that line
through it to use analogy I was using
earlier where like I'm not a Centrist by
any scent of the term that implies some
measure of moderation I'm like you're a
radical of a certain kind we could put
the an American radical right right wing
left wing let's put that to one side a
lot of what I say I think appeals or
should appeal if I may say so myself to
people that you would put on the radical
far left not the woke left that's a
different thing
but it but a version of the left that
probably ought to be oh it's owes it to
self itself to be as adamant as I am on
our position with respect to Ukraine
which is we need to get the hell out
and our position on NATO which is that
the institution has outlived its purpose
and yet ironically grew more after the
fall of the USSR than it ever did before
or to call out the corruption just of
the last week that we saw that
apparently Biden and it may as well have
been Dick Cheney if you flip the rolls
but today it's Biden was informed three
months before the explosion at the
Nordstrom pipeline
that Ukraine Was preparing to do it the
CIA was informed Biden was informed and
yet after it happened described it as a
deliberate Act of sabotage pinning it on
the Russians right this is
this is wrong right this is wrong and it
has nothing to do with right or left but
that's a far left View
it's increasingly now I'm labeled as
being on the far right Fringe for saying
it so it's not that like I call
like it's I'm not in the middle the
exhausted middle there the exhausted the
middle there in some ways the problem
right the neocons and the in the
Republican party and much of the Biden
establishment in the Democratic party so
so whatever it is it's not middle but
it's something else altogether well
um as you correctly Intuit you and I are
on the same page here
um I'm just borrowing their term they
called it yeah sounds good in my
taxonomy I would say
um that the center is where we meet to
discuss fate of the nation right it's it
doesn't mean that you are of the center
but the center is the right place to
meet to discuss these things right it is
yes the The Hot Spot in your scatter
plot
um and so I I agree with that and I also
you know I'm I'm watching the um
I'm watching The Blue Team embrace all
kinds of things that I would have called
uh reactionary right it's pro-war
footing I find absolutely stunning it's
interesting censorship is beyond bizarre
um so in any case you know I I don't
take any of these labels for granted but
I would say that I do think what the
hidden tribes report called the
exhausted middle is actually
it is the essence of the thing to which
all of us Patriots from across the
entire map uh resonate it is it is that
Central agreement that we are not going
to
prioritizes anybody anybody's particular
view or their right to access the market
that the best we can do is a system that
liberates you as much as possible
individually liberates you as much as
possible creates as much opportunity as
it can
creates as level a playing field as is
possible does not seek to redistribute
the gains of those who have invested uh
in some extra way or produced some extra
measure of insight or some Innovation
right we all agree on this or at least
we did until
I don't know 10 years ago and then we
differed over some other things and now
all of the things that we once agreed on
are under threat not because most of us
have changed our minds that's the
interesting part we most of us if you
ask the questions well still agree on
those principles I think you're right
about that I think you're dead right
about that and I think I even go one
step further than that most of us agree
on those basic principles most of us
think that our neighbors or our
classmates or our colleagues or our
teammates or our
parents of our kids classmates also
share those principles in common but we
don't feel sure about it anymore because
we don't feel free to talk about it in
the open
and so that's why I think
free speech is I think the ultimate tool
of the anti-establishment movement and
or or to the contrary censorship is the
ultimate tool of the existing
establishment which makes the divisions
that we perceive
feel more real than they really are
actually and I think that's where we are
in the country and which which is
actually that sounds dark that's
actually an optimistic thing to say
it's a deeply optimistic thing to say I
think we just have to call that bluff by
starting to talk openly again and I
think what do we see
there's this you know the expression of
the Overton window my campaign is all
about driving a truck through that
window maybe that gets me censored on
LinkedIn for a while but that's I think
something that
is actually heartening if it's possible
we call that bluff and it turns out 80
percent of this country agrees on those
basic rules of the road that's that's
something and the only reason I resist
that framing of the middle is sometimes
I think it leads to sort of
uh I would say
undesirable actions that we take that
are substantive I mean I think a lot of
the there's a lot of where I have a
different point of view than what Elon
has said about Twitter and what he wants
to do there where like at the time he
took it over as shortly after he took it
over I think he said something like I
mean he's
wearing the mantle of anti-establishment
pro Free Speech position here
but
I I do find concerning some of the
things that he said and some of the
things that are happening are actually
not again errors but are consistent with
actually the stated design of the
product which was that like I think I'm
quoting him exactly from what he said in
New York last fall which is
you know maybe the far left and the far
right maybe we don't want them but for
the 80 percent of the people who are in
the middle we need a place to converse
to have open discourse and debate to be
clear that's
decidedly better than I suppose a
machine that only includes sixty percent
of of the people
starting at one into the political
Spectrum or 30 of people that went into
the political Spectrum that's the
progressive one but I don't think it's
the
definition of a free speech platform to
say that there's still some
determination of what counts as being in
the proverbial middle and saying that
we're a platform for that it's a it's a
pro-censorship Centrist platform than a
pro censorship
you know left-wing one
or pro-censorship right-wing one for
that matter and so I think that that's
where I view some of the dangers of the
new
establishment wearing the
anti-establishment mantle
um because I think that it does Trick
some people to go along with it and
still think that they're challenging an
establishment when in fact it's just a
new establishment or a reboot of an
existing one I think would be very
careful in making sure that we don't
fall into the labels of who's far left
or far right I think we I think it's
much more important that we suspend
those designations for now and start to
just ask what's true
and then let's see where the chips fall
and maybe a couple years from now we can
go back to debating what being on the
left or the right or the far left or the
far right actually mean
yeah I think that's fair I
strongly agree with you about the
uncertainty that now characterizes
Americans with respect to what their
neighbors believe and the role that
censorship plays in adjusting their
certainty in the downward Direction and
I will say I until very recently lived
in Portland Oregon and my wife and I
took up the uh experiment of
speaking openly
about what we thought was true and in
Portland
you would think that everybody was on
board with um
diversity equity and inclusion with uh
so-called uh gender affirming care you
would think that these things were
agreed on by everybody that they were
enthusiastic about
um you know vaccines mandates masks Etc
but our experience was as soon as we
indicated to people that we actually
disagreed with much of the conventional
wisdom
people almost reflexively confessed
their own doubts
it was like I mean it was it was rare
that this didn't happen where you would
say to somebody you know actually I'm
not on board with that and they didn't
come back with yeah I'm not either and
then they would have their own story to
tell about where their doubts came from
so it's like the entire population was
um
Keeping Up Appearances so as not to be
out of phase with some consensus that
actually I think literally doesn't exist
that there was effectively nobody on
board with it
um you know I'm sure there are some
people in the extremes and I wasn't
running into them but the people you run
into in the normal course of interaction
people who have jobs and are trying to
feed families and keep a roof over their
heads they're not nearly as confused as
we are being led to believe
um and I find your your interact the
idea that you as a candidate for
president are not allowed to voice a uh
a perspective on climate or energy
policy that is out of phase like how
insane is that for one thing if you if
your perspective was wrong wouldn't you
want a presidential candidate to say
those things so that we could say oh
this person believes a bunch of wrong
stuff yeah it's insane uh I think that
in some ways that was the easier example
actually so the one that happened on
LinkedIn with Microsoft own LinkedIn
censoring me that's the easy example the
reason that so so let's get let's get
real here okay good like in the moment
we're in right now
I'll tell you what my first instinct was
when they sent back some of those crazy
emails it was like oh
this is actually probably going to be
pretty good for me because this is so
nuts that all I literally had to do was
to post these emails
and I've got the entire
right-wing ecosystem coming to my rescue
and some of the left too and like you
know
it's it's sort of a silly game but it's
like this game of primary presidential
politics is like you're day trading for
attention and it's it's a silly game and
I hate playing it I'm trying not to but
there's a version of it where it's
inevitable so I was like oh this is this
is going to be this is going to be a
good thing and
by and large you know most of the media
got out of it it was quite favorable
because Microsoft buckled trying to
claim it was an error covering their
tracks so that's the easy version
let me give you the hard version you're
gonna just get a little real here where
this is the new
uh establishment and anti-establishment
clothing
right so so I'm a free speech absolutist
I don't know how you would characterize
yourself pretty pretty close uh there
let's put it this way the where I differ
would be around
issues uh
uh of terrorizing you know doxing people
is it anybody's right to put Tucker
Carlson's address oh that's not free
that's not free that's not even free so
so let me give you my definition of free
speech absolutism okay because that's
not free speech right or posting you
know
child pornography no like that's not the
expression of an opinion so that's where
I go
the expression of an opinion yeah so
what it means to have a free spirit any
opinion yep should be expressed and the
state should not be making foremost the
state of all should not be making
judgments about which opinions can and
cannot be expressed in certain forums
if it is discriminating on the basis of
opinion yep within within reason right I
don't want to create a loophole for
let's say pedophiles to disguise things
as opinions yeah yeah no no no no
disguising of opinions but but but if
it's an opinion like a true opinion an
actual opinion no matter how vile right
right okay so that's what I mean when I
call myself a free speech absolutist it
sounds like you are too no matter how
vile the opinion right that's what
matters Okay so
there's a funny thing that happened
um you know Florida this year well the
Santa is running or in the run-ups
running for president
signs a law
uh it's a law that was in response to a
trend of people Distributing leaflets
that you know contain I think some
bad stuff with respect to you know
anti-semitic content or or religious
minorities they're saying bad things
about
and you know people distribute leaflets
to people's homes of various kinds
some of them are commercial leaflets
some of them are political candidates
that's very common but these other
people are Distributing these other
leaflets that are deemed to contain
content that harass religious minorities
so they pass a law
it's actually while he was traveling
abroad but he passes a law that says you
that there's going to be criminal
penalties potentially jail time
associated with violating this law that
involves
Distributing lit litter as they call it
literature included that would
specifically it Flags harass or
intimidate a member of a religious
minority group something like this is
exact almost exactly what the law says
I'm a free speech absolutist
I
do not condone
bigoted hateful harassing speech
but as a free speech absolutist I
believe the right answer to bad speeches
not less speeches more speech so I said
so on Twitter
I said and I think I said you know the
the recently passed hate speech law in
Florida with due respect I disagree with
it
there's something interesting that
happened I mean there's a there was a
swarm of
an online Army that Flags to
Twitter's uh support function
the community notes function
that says hey this is false this speech
is false a quitter Twitter community no
it said behest of some of DeSantis
largest fans adds a note that says this
is suggest saying that there's an
inaccuracy in this tweet that this is
not a hate speech law
I said I disagree with the hate speech
law this is not a hate speech law per se
every time you had a per se to a
centralized determination of Truth it
tells you a lot about whether it should
have been added in the first place
so I
nonetheless said that this is actually a
centralized determination of truth
that's part of my problem with Elon Musk
issue is that I don't think we should
have mature majoritarian determinations
of Truth Or Not the tweets to which
Community notes are added it is widely
believed or algorithmically boosted
downward or suppressed rather than
boosted
so what I see there is sort of a new
anti-establishment
front
that is actually just implementing an
establishment agenda which is a law
that's passed
that effectively is
speech suppressive at the margin right
this is about private property rights I
love private property rights but that
doesn't mean that if you're going to as
the state say there's certain opinions
you can distribute via leaflet on
private property but other opinions
which you can't
if they contain harassing content to a
to a religious minority group that is
the definition of hate speech law but
not only are they passing the hate
speech law we're now going to use paid
influencers on the internet to flag to a
internet platform that launched my
presidential campaign to say that it is
false to call that a hate speech law
that is actually like I think far more
dangerous than the Microsoft LinkedIn
episode in the moment we live in today
five years ago the Microsoft LinkedIn
Day episode was the more dangerous one
because then there was no necessary
ability to
call out that farce for what it is and
so what the establishment is it moves
but I'm kind of making a I was making
some notes as you were talking here's to
me how I in the year what are we talking
about June of 2023
I think Hallmarks of the new
establishment that I see that spans both
political parties it is pro-war in
Ukraine
it is anti-free speech
it is comprised of people on both sides
of this so-called partisan divide who
refuse to engage in open debate with
their political opponents on
unconstrained settings they talk a lot
about Republicans and Democrats like a
lot using capital r and capital D they
talk a lot about the radical right and
the radical left and their
universally their principal source of
funding is super Pacs
oh and by the way at least on the right
you see it more now wearing an
anti-establishment mantle to me those
are at least like in 2025 it'll be
something different than it is today and
in 2020 it was something different than
it is now but right now I think that the
new establishment pro-war in Ukraine
anti-speech refused to debate the other
side talks a lot about Republicans and
Democrats donor-funded principally via
super Pacs those are the Hallmarks of
what it means to be an establishment
today I think the version that's I'm
seeing cropping up in the Republican
party is far more concerning to me in
this primary process than
the version that I was railing against
when I wrote woke Inc a couple of years
ago I don't know if any of that made
sense to you but that's what I see right
now in the current landscape as I'm
experiencing it no it makes perfect
sense to me I will add one thing to it
which you may well disagree with but
that the
Central role that influence peddling has
played in the shaping of the modern
versions of both of our major parties
has actually produced
almost through a back door in my opinion
a kind of de facto fascism which is the
the sort of
central element of the new establishment
perspective that you're describing in
other words
this is the fusion of uh
corporate power with governance that is
the sin quanon of fascism yes and these
are the things that that Fusion now
desires it desires to be able to control
people's speech so it cannot be
dislodged from power or exposed it seeks
to limit the access to remedies that are
actually
um inalienable by designation right it
it is it finds democracy and
constitutional rights to be the ultimate
inconvenience and it is doing everything
to cryptically unhook those processes
thereby stranding a citizenry with kind
of a you know a shell of its Former
Republic
um so I do see it clearly and
I will say with respect to your point
about
Community notes the difficult version of
uh censorship and what to think about it
we are in a kind of arms race and I
think I'm probably more sympathetic
to musk's position than you are it
sounds like I'm concerned by some of the
moves I've seen him make that I don't
understand uh I don't understand the new
CEO the choice of yakumino in part
because of the w e f connection uh the
wokeness the um
the whole package looks very concerning
but I will say in musk's defense
not on the yakarino choice which I think
is just simply a mistake but with
respect to managing a platform like this
it is not easy to figure out how to draw
the line of a free speech absolutist
without carving out an exception for
things that absolutely do not belong on
the platform
and so anyway I would just say he may be
screwing it up but it's not like I could
tell him how not to right yeah I've
written actually I've actually written
an extensive
um
you know I wrote a piece on this in the
Wall Street Journal shortly after he
announced or his intention to
potentially buy Twitter uh that actually
does lay out how this can be done uh
it's not my passion to run a social
media company although I don't think he
picked the right person to do it either
but I do think that no Viewpoint
discrimination has to be part of the
list that means hate speech goes away as
a category yeah now illegal content
totally goes away spam porn all of that
forget about like that's not the
expression of an opinion yep but no
Viewpoint discrimination and then when
in doubt give the user the choice to
decide what they do and don't want to
see to set their own filters accordingly
rather than to make Central
determinations of truth of any kind I
think that's part of was the problem
you've been through the version of this
with the covet determinations of truth
right I don't think Community notes is
that much more helpful under conditions
of
fear an epidemic of the real epidemic
was fear in our country anymore or maybe
it's a slightly better but not that much
better than a centralized determination
made by a small body of corporate
Executives either especially when those
corporate Executives control the
supposedly Community notes function it
might just be risk it might just be
wrapped up in an anti-establishment
veneer like I said so I think that there
is a way to do this but I think that it
is uh it is a question of principles
it's not an implementation difficulty
there's all kinds of implementation
difficulty but that's not the hardest
part questions what's the normative View
and I think if you're going in saying
that you want to serve the 80 of the
people in the middle but not the
so-called far left or far right that
means you believe that there are certain
opinions that should not be expressed
and it's a much wider aperture than the
old guard right but it still means that
you're not committed to the idea that
all that there's no such thing as a
wrong opinion and I am and and and we I
I myself believe that we should be able
to debate that and so I respectfully
debate that and have different points of
view from folks like you know musk or
DeSantis et cetera on this question that
doesn't mean they're bad people that
just means that we have different
opinions on this actually respect a lot
of the strides that Elon has made it
heroic in in the progress that we've
made in the right direction but I think
it's important that we make progress
towards the right North Star and that's
I think what I'm going to be
Unapologetic about
yeah uh I'm on board with that
um you do raise the question and I think
uh I said at the beginning of covid
that I believed
well I have a general principle which is
that some stories by their very nature
diagnose the system that watching the
system process a given story reveals the
nature of the system as much as it
reveals anything about the story in
question and I said at the beginning of
covid
that it was a story that was going to
diagnose our system it was going to let
us understand
uh the Deep Corruption of that system
how far it reached and in fact I believe
I was right about this it lets us see
the corruption of our academic
institutions of our journalistic
institutions of our government
it let us see how far into our
personal discussions the government was
capable of reaching how thoroughly it
could breach our rights
and you know I would say the report card
you know we got an F and the only reason
we got an F is because there's no lower
grade right covered all of these defects
and I know that in part because I was on
the wrong end of that sensorious
instinct uh for almost the entire time
uh Heather and I began discussing covet
as biologists on Dark Horse and it
resulted in us quickly becoming
demonetized by YouTube which they've
never reversed even though they were
wrong on the substance of what they
complained about
um and we feel their thumb uh or the
thumb of whatever it is that guides
YouTube their thumb is still on the
scale not only at YouTube but we feel it
at Twitter and I don't think that's
musk's doing I think there's something
deeply embedded in his machine that
still uh would like to keep us from
reaching an audience even though we've
been Vindicated across the board with
respect to what what we uh understood
but in any case corporate deep corporate
is the counterpart to the Deep State I
think it exists it's part of this
managerial bureaucracy that spans the
public sector the private sector the
associate deans of God knows what at
universities it's a it's a separate kind
of DNA and it's a different kind of gene
pool it is the wholesale capture of
every structure on which we depend there
seems to be not a single institution
that has been able to resist this the
only thing that resists it are small
numbers of individuals who are not
beholden to anyone
and so it does raise a question I do
want to ask you I don't know your
position either during the so-called
pandemic or your position now on what
happened during the pandemic but as
somebody who had his life turned
completely upside down over these issues
I am very interested in what you thought
and what you think now and how it it
would affect uh your uh your power in
governance if you did make it to the
presidency
yeah so I think that
the
virus originated in a lab
in Wuhan China
it was engineered
and it was engineered by
a form of research
gain a function research that was banned
here in the United States
but was nonetheless funded in part using
U.S taxpayer dollars because of the
Rogue behavior of U.S government actors
in the Deep State who disagreed with
that policy
and taxpayer dollars and the law be
damned funded it anyway
under the excuse of preventing a global
pandemic
that gave us a global pandemic instead
then they funded uses taxpayer dollars
again
to fund the creation of vaccines
to prevent the spread of that pandemic
in the name of helping the human the
health of a general population
that ended up covering up many of the
health risks associated with that
vaccine it happened by no coincidence to
be some of the very same actors
that literally funded the creation of
the pandemic that then went on to create
from the creation of the vaccines again
dressed up in the Garb of helping
Humanity
did not help Humanity in the way that
they professed to
and then we see the rise of
uh policy response
that
in the name of helping human Humanity
made all kinds of mistakes that leave us
worse off even along the very health
axes depression anxiety education of our
children obesity diabetes cancer
treatment and so on
that
are net worse on health axes alone let
alone economic axes just Health axes
alone than they otherwise would have
been had we not adopted those policies
yet the very companies that were able to
censor any debate about those policies
were the principal beneficiaries
financially of those policies that
includes most of the Silicon Valley
establishment
so I could probably go on for hours but
in summary that is roughly what I think
is the some of the most useful parts
that we could actually learn lessons
from to stop us from making the same
mistakes again as I otherwise predict
we're well on track to with respect to
the culture of the climate to The Cult
of the climate that I think is in the
early stages of on track of repeating
the mistakes of the covet biosecurity
State I think we're now approaching the
beginnings of a climate Security State
that's going to repeat every one of
those same mistakes Lock Stock and
Barrel in their new form
excellent well uh you did spectacularly
well from my perspective having uh
watched and participated in the battle
over
covid there are a couple points I would
add to your list
um going forward
um the hardest nut to crack in all of
the coveted landscape has been the
question of early treatment with
repurposed drugs where a large number of
people who have figured out that the
vaccines were not safe nor effective
still believe the propaganda that they
were fed over early treatment with
repurposed drugs
um that's a very deep rabbit hole
because there's a reason that the
propaganda was so
um aggressive with respect to this issue
in other words
the um
the release of the vaccines required
there not to be an alternative for the
euas to be granted so that is in my
opinion the reason that this has been
the hardest of these to clear up but
anyway it's worth looking into what
actually took place with respect to
repurposed drugs and also if you you
know
hydroxychloroquine and Ivermectin are
their own uh can of worms but even just
the failure to recommend
vitamin D for a population that is well
understood to be vitamin D deficient
and the massive increase in health that
could have been achieved relative to
covid if we had been honest about
exposure to Sun and if you can't get
enough exposure to Sun supplementation
with vitamin D that was a tremendous
missed opportunity and a very
frightening absence from the
recommendations because it literally uh
you know to the extent that there are
side effects to vitamin D they would
have been positive right it's an amazing
thing for us to have missed the other
thing that I didn't hear in your
description was
the role that our vaccination campaign
likely played in the evolution of viral
variants in other words did we produce
an ongoing pandemic of course we did
though yeah by definition right you know
because and I think that that acts
actually deeply related to being a
man-made virus in the first place
um of course this gets into the um into
the attributes of the way in which
attributes of a man-made virus that did
not naturally evolve in nature
themselves create risk of variants that
were at a different way of let's just
say um
you know let's just say evolutionary
microevolutionary change that's
different of a Kind than you had from
one that originated in nature right and
you know you have a generation
engineered versus drift and show on so
on yeah yeah you have an engineered
virus uh that one should not expect to
abide by the same rules that a natural
exact event would have produced and then
you have an absurdly narrow so-called
vaccine that creates an evolutionary
signal that is so uh targeted that you
know of course natural selection would
overcome any uh benefit from these
vaccines because the vaccines are just
simply not broad enough to create a
difficult puzzle to solve right
selection is very good at solving a
puzzle and with a single antigen that
was guaranteed
but
uh
the last thing I would say is a couple
weeks ago Heather and I were prone to
look at the
coveted response in light of the
Nuremberg code which I'm embarrassed to
say I had not gone back and re-read
since covid began I knew that our
vaccine campaign in particular was a
violation because
uh informed consent was uh
was breached twice right couldn't
possibly be informed if they were
censoring viewpoints right you were
misinformed
and
it wasn't a matter of consent because we
were coerced but when we went back and
looked at the provisions of the
Nuremberg code I was surprised to
discover that we appear to have violated
every single one of them
interesting these are Provisions about
which in 1947 even though they had not
yet been codified seven doctors were
hanged on the basis that we had violated
or that they had violated
this obvious principle derived from the
Hippocratic Oath so in any case
I do believe
that this is another one of these
examples of something that if you stand
in the right place and you look back at
our coveted response it's so clear
that what happened wasn't just wrong but
it was an egregious violation of a
central principle of medicine and not
even modern medicine but totally
stretching way back that it's worth
looking at it through that lens
um I agree with you I I think the fact
that there's people like you who also
now are not going to let this just go
gently into the night but make sure we
learn these lessons
is vitally important
for actually our
best way of preventing making that same
mistake in the future would be the
global pandemic or even a what I think
is increasingly made up change of
existential threat of global climate
change and
I'm with you on that I think that we're
just at the beginnings of
uncovering all of the sins that were
committed under covid some of which were
intentional I think some of this is
being attributed incompetence I think is
too charitable and I think that without
actual accountability
for some of the individuals who actually
committed the
most offensive of the sins who are now
being by the way invited as commencement
speakers this spring at prominent
medical schools oh God you know I think
that without accountability including
potential criminal penalties we're gonna
put ourselves at risk of making those
same mistakes again yeah I would also
say even if covid and medical you know I
agree with you this can't possibly have
been incompetence because incompetence
can get you to a effectively random
response it can't get you to the inverse
of a
correct response and in this case we did
almost the inverse of everything we do
at T right to a t so
um but I also think even just going the
exercise of going back and figuring out
how our response to covid happened
is probably the best chance we're ever
going to get to understand the
corruption of our system because it
really does reveal the connections
between the broken governmental response
the universities and universities
science uh journalism the tech sector
all of these things their connections
are revealed by the story and so no I'm
not going to let it go because I think
it's very important that we use it to
diagnose the the illness that our system
has and to cure it
um and it sounds sounds like you are on
a similar page which I I greatly
appreciate
amen my man I am I am I'm I uh
[Music]
it's probably the most enjoyable
conversation I've had in a little while
awesome I'm I'm pleased to hear that I
know I need to let you go I'm grateful
for it you've been very generous with
your time and even more importantly than
that it is so refreshing to have a
conversation with as much at stake as
any presidential candidate would see
that you've been absolutely willing to
explore openly to share viewpoints to
reposition anyway it's refreshing and
um let's just say if you make it to the
present presidency
um I will be thrilled to see a
courageous capable Patriot in that
office and and hopeful for the future
appreciate it man I uh
I'd like to say I won't let you down but
uh
that's a long time from now I think the
part where I'll say I won't let you down
is in this process
I'll
speak truth be totally transparent
rather lose the election than to play
some political Snakes and Ladders
and I just think that that happens to be
right now if I had to bet the winning
strategy because I think the people are
wising up like you said but
either way that's how we're gonna do
this and uh and hopefully this won't be
the last time we chat beautiful well uh
good luck to you sir and I look forward
to uh seeing you down the road a piece
appreciate it all right I'm excited be
well
[Music]